we got another guest here who we want to
bring in and um I really do appreciate
uh we're going to bring in Mr Epstein
here he's going to talk about this I
want your reaction here to what's going
on Julian you you you've been in the
house uh Judiciary Committee as a senior
Council there uh what's your reaction to
this yeah I also I voted for Joe Biden I
did not vote for Donald Trump either in
16 or 20 I think this is a terrible
decision I think it's an anti-democratic
position and I think it shows how out of
touch the professional left has gotten
they live in sort of an insular bubble
and I don't think they realize how bad
this looks across the country um from a
legal point of view there are two real
problems with this attempt to Bar Trump
from the primary ballots the first
problem is a complete lack of due
process uh there is absolutely no due
process in making this determination
these are made mostly by political
figures uh democ professional Democrats
uh who obviously have an ma to grind uh
secondly it's very unlikely in my
opinion that the section three of the
14th amendment was intended to apply to
presidents there are enumerated official
Senators Representatives electors uh
it's officers of the United States I I
think it's unlikely that it would ever
apply to a president of the United
States further in none of the
prosecutions uh you've seen of President
Trump including Jack Smith's prosecution
for the January 6th um uh matter uh are
they attempting to prosecute under an
Insurrection statute um they Congress
has under the 14th Amendment an
opportunity to Bar uh a potential uh
federal office holder from holding
office including a president if they
want to using the insruction Clause
Congress went for impeachment they
didn't use uh Insurrection uh for
whatever reason there's lot there's been
lots of opportunities to test whether
the president's conduct on January 6th
amounted to Illegal Insurrection and at
every instance Democrats have declined
to do it now they use this backdoor
process and I think it's sort of it just
looks bad and so that that's from a
legal point of view from a political
point of view what you've heard
Democrats talking about since really
2015 is what an incredible threat Donald
Trump is to democracy and to the
democratic ideals of the United States
in the west and then they go out there
with this attempt to deny half the
American people who will likely be
supporting
uh president Trump in uh in the next
election um deny the opportunity for uh
them to choose him in the primary and it
just seems very hard for in my mind for
Democrats to square this argument about
promoting democracy promoting sort of
free choice all of these ideals these
high-minded ideals and then excluding
Trump uh from a primary ballot I I think
this will be regarded historically as
something that was very
foolish appreciate your perspective on
this hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else